all right wow here it is wesley so
magnus carlsen fourth and final game
and it has started it has started so a
king's pawn opening
magnus going back to his strategy from
yesterday in this position
wesley did bring out his night yesterday
and actually wesley with the white
pieces he lost the first one yesterday
winning the second
and this time he plays a different
opening we're going for the berlin
defense the spanish opening
wesley okay pushing a pawn there this is
all known stuff
oh no oh no we're heading for a draw are
we
wow wesley throwing away the advantage
of the white pieces i said this was his
best chance to win
but he's heading straight for the tie
breaks this is a well-known draw
wesley's played it
dozens of times in this tour so far
quick repetition look
look at magnus's face he's surprised
look at magnus he's shocked that wesley
went for this wesley has been destroying
him with the white pieces
why go for a quick draw in this fashion
okay we're down to blitz though
this is uh dramatic in the final between
these two
wesley so going for the quick draw he
wants
to take this one to thai